non honnêtement c'est un vrai un vrai
bonheur pour moi d'être là un vrai
bonheur est une vraie émotion surtout
que c'était à la suite d'une longue
persécutions menée par amina et loose
qui m'a beaucoup beaucoup appelé c'est
une femme redoutable et je suis heureux
de me retrouver ici avec vous avec des
amis très chers à moi qui sont ici que
je vois que je reconnais dans la
pénombre vous m'entendez vraiment un
parce que chaque mot est important alors
parlons d'abord de mots quand on m'a dit
effervescence et regarder dans le
dictionnaire effervescence tu vas parler
poids je ne sais pas d'effervescence ah
bon alors j'ai cherché effervescence de
poing bouillonnement tumultueux j'aime
la suite
produit par le dégagement rapide d'agaza
rapide et je sais pas pourquoi ça j'aime
moins les gaz tout ça j'aime j'aime pas
trop donc surtout
surtout quand le gaz s'est associé au
mot détails
j'aime pas du tout donc j'étais un peu
comme ça un peu embêté comme ça et c'est
bon j'ai continué sa continuer à être de
plus en plus compliquée sous forme de
bulles sagem bu le champagne tout sagem
qui viennent crever à la surface voilà
l'effervescence j'aime pas trop le mot
crevé je sais pas pourquoi vous êtes
comme moi peut-être ne sais pas en tout
cas bon l'ensemble ne convenait surtout
que ça continue et dans le dictionnaire
bouillonnement agitation vives de nature
politique sociale alors là en principe
j'aime intellectuelle ou émotionnelle
alors là j'adore donc vous voyez c'était
un sujet vraiment je remercie tête x
d'avoir choisi effervescence pour moi
j'ai bien compris que c'était
spécialement destinée et donc j'en suis
très très sensible et très sensible
donc je suis moi en pleine effervescence
devant vous avec vous grâce à ted chez
moi chez vous dans votre tunisie dans ma
tunisie fait que cette tunisie j'allais
laisser derrière moi quand j'avais 11
ans à la mort de mon père et de ma mère
paradis perdu pour moi puis terre
frappée comme d'interdits
j'avais l'impression de ne pas y revenir
parce que j'avais l'impression de voir
des morts partout des morts derrière les
fenêtres de la maison que j'habite et
des morts comme ça ailleurs le cimetière
des morts et rang des esprits fantôme je
n'arrivais pas à y aller j'ai pu
retourner la première fois j'avais 21
ans 22 ans grâce et avec une caméra la
caméra me protéger du réel et j'ai
commencé à faire mon premier
documentaire en tunisie est jeune mais
il fallait goji cette caméra il fallait
que j'aie cette caméra pour pouvoir
filmer la tunisie 10 ans après donc la
mort des parents en 67 68 par là et s'il
a pu rentrer en tunisie comme ça sinon
je je crois que j'aurais jamais eu la
force le courage qu'on va pour ça qu'on
veut de retourner en tunisie
mais alors cette vie de documentariste
cette vie de journaliste cette vie de
producteur de télévision
elle a commencé ici entre le colisée le
palmarium le mondial tous à aix peyrat
et je suis devenu un fan éthique de
cinéma ici je n'étais pas le seul
on était tous ou de cinéma on y passait
sa vie et j'étais fou dessins de piper
laurie c'est comme ça c'est une actrice
de l'époque qui jouait dans la flèche le
flambeau un admirable film d'ailleurs de
jacques tourneur
après quand je suis devenu cinéphile je
disais oui si jacques tourneur que tout
ça alors que j'étais obsédé parce qu'il
y avait le cinéma devant le lycée carnot
je séchais comme ça et j'allais voir les
seins de kipé alors y est je me disais
un jour quand je serai grand hyper
laurie tombera amoureuse de moi ça
traîne un peu mais ça viendra
ça viendra jo futur alors voilà cette
passion intacte vieille tunisoise a
commencé quand j'avais 8 7 8 ans lorsque
je voulais devenir aussi danseur étoile
mais le problème c'est que j'ai un peu
forcé mais ça a été une vieille passion
il y avait une dame russe d'origine
russe qui donnait des cours comme ça oui
peut-être
et je sais pas sur quelles mais trouvait
formidable novembre elle m'encourager et
puis voilà le la france le monde a perdu
un danseur étoile
on s'en remet difficilement on se remet
difficilement mais c'est comme ça et
c'est maintenant bon un ex danseur
étoile est devant vous et il est heureux
d'être dans le seul pays au monde où au
fond dès l'aéroport et l'odeur du
détergent
j'aime le seul pays au monde le seul
pays au monde où quand je fais des
gestes comme ça on me trouve sobre pour
moi c'est exceptionnel c'est
exceptionnel parce qu'en général quand
je me vois à la télé en france je vous
dis mais comment tu fais autant de
gestes des mecs me dise arrête arrête de
bouger comme ça ici je suis british ça
va c'est normal on ne fait pas rentrer
parquet et cetera bombay s'est très très
bien et c'est ici dans les souks un que
j'ai appris le goût de l'autre différent
et fraternelle la tolérance avec celui
qui est différent et fraternelle
le dialogue et l'écouté et bien sûr
pardonnez-moi la négociation et ce à
toutes ses vertus sont indispensables
pour l'exercice du malheureux métier qui
est le mien que j'essaye de faire tant
bien que mal depuis maintenant plus de
55 ans figurez vous donc c'est terry
puisque j'ai commencé à travailler à 17
ans j'ai quitté les classes que ça mais
je me suis mis à travailler parce qu'il
fallait il fallait le faire et j'avais
cette espèce de passion folle qui
consistait à filmer les gens et à garder
une trace des gens moi qui n'avais plus
trace de mes parents disparus je voulais
absolument filmer les gens et donc j'ai
commencé à travailler très tôt et je
continue mon dernier film las et il va
passer bientôt
c'est un film sur le ministère de
l'intérieur en france voyez quelle
intuition admirable qui a assis son
admirable
je fume quoi je filme les attentats en
coulisses en france on y reviendra
avant-hier à la résidence de france de
l'ambassade de france là une dame
charmante une éditrice m'annonce qu'elle
a résidé longtemps au 79 rue courbet
devenu 79 que de palestine pour les plus
jeunes de lasalle et ya que des jeunes
dans cette salle donc 79 2 rue de
palestine ma maison natale et elle me
dit comme ça froidement calmement
durement mais gentiment ça n'existe
je suis allé ce matin là à côté la rue
de palestine
il ya un trou à la place de ma maison et
al et c était un coup rude
en même temps c'est le signe de la
vitalité de cette ville qui détruit ses
maisons mais ça m'a fait un drôle
d'effet ou l'imaginé volontiers
il ya même plus de trace de sa et la
fois dernière lors de mon dernier voyage
c'était la tombe de mes parents au
cimetière juif du borgel qui avait été
éventré par le temps péri donc bon alors
voilà c'est comme ça on peut dire c'est
comme ça on peut dire que c'est l'avenir
qui compte c'est demain qui compte et
c'est ça qui me paraît important mais ce
qui est important pour moi aussi c'est
que mes enfants depuis qu'ils sont nés
je les amène ici depuis qu'ils sont
comme ça et ils sont comme ça donc c'est
bien et il aime la tunisie donc ça va
continuer l'histoire des moati en
tunisie alors voilà savez l'un d'eux
tout ça des maisons des cimetières des
machins ça suffit il me reste des
bouquins j'ai recréé tous âges en effet
une légende c'est ça au fond un mon
métier c'est de transformer la réalité
en légende et quand on transforme en
légende c'est bien ça donnait des
bouquins qui sont imparfaits des films
moyens mais c'est ma légende à moi c'est
ma façon de refaire vivre les choses les
gens les êtres humains des histoires
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait ce métier et
ses métiers réalisateur journaliste
producteur animateur de télé tout ça à
la fois dire je déteste quand ça ne
bouge pas effervescence
je déteste pas ça ne bouge pas je
déteste quand on est tous dans consensus
je déteste l'ennui jeu d'épaisses le nom
mouvement et donc effervescence on va
dire alors c'est une digue contre le
temps mon métier les images elles ne
meurent pas et la voix des morts et
désistera toujours alors quand je passe
une frontière ont dit quel est votre
métier voiture je vous connais j'aime
bien ce que vous faites
je vais très bien merci beaucoup c'est
gentil ça on pourra vous me demandez mon
métier dit ben il faut mettre profession
j'ai dit mais je sais pas je sais pas
faire je ne sais pas préfère du tout
alors que j'ai pas de métier vraiment
j'ai tout ça à la fois comme métier jeu
mais j'ai envie de m mais je ne vais pas
évidemment gardien de la mémoire des
morts
je fais pas damman se fait pas le mec
qui ne renverrait immédiatement au
cimetière mais c'est vrai que j'aime ça
j'aime filmer ça et ça m'importe de le
faire et je suis accompagnateurs
maintenant des vivants parce que
vraiment j'ai envie de vous dire quelque
chose c'est par rapport à ce que nous
avons vécu collectivement est ce que
vous avez vécu ici vivent les vivants
regardez regardez moi je vous parle ici
et dans cette salle on a tous des morts
qui rôde et c'est important je crois de
les sentir présent parmi nous aussi pour
j'en ai fait un métier pour être tous
vivants et fraternelle ça ne me paraît
le plus important quand je continue et
je reprends ce que nous dit le dico le
contraire de l'effervescence c'est
l'apaisement le canapé la quiétude la
tranquillité je connais pas je connais
pas ou alors c'est très très fugitif le
matin parfois une barque qui part du
port de sidi bou saïd
je les fais tellement de fois et c'est
leurs retrouvailles avec la mer we dance
est dans ce matin magnifique du monde
comme ça qui se lève
oui j'ai connu la paix le calme la
tranquillité qu'est ce qu'ils disent la
quiétude avec tout ça afin la fois c'est
dans le contraire de l'effervescence mai
mais très vite bon sac disparaissait up
du vent tourne il faut rentrer au port
machin mais bon il paraît que c'est ça
le comble et on je retournais cette
méditerranée que j'aime tant la mer là
notre label la seule avant qu'elle ne se
transforme parfois hélas en cimetière
marin pour des pauvres gens tentés par
un eldorado lointain une terre promise
inatteignable alors à propos terme amis
de terre promise
vous savez quoi c'est aujourd'hui hier
et pendant quelques jours la pâques
chrétiennes et la pâque juive
hazard chevassier des hasards
c'est le hasard des dates entre
calendrier solaire et calendrier lunaire
si je répète ce qu'on m'a dit
or hier soir à la marsa nous étions une
trentaine autour de la table juifs
presque tous les juifs de tunisie
musulmans évidemment les frères se
d'enfance est ce toujours d'aujourd'hui
et des chrétiens bien sûr à fêter la
pâques le plus beau de cette cérémonie
c'est que c'était un musulman qui a lu
la prière juive
ça va toucher vous ne pouvez pas savoir
combien c'était là et ça m'a rappelé
évidemment ces petits musique que j'ai
tellement connu dans mon enfance et
tunisie tolérante fraternelle ouverte
accueillante à la différence j'ai
tellement aimé ça j'ai tellement aimé ça
que ça soit ce musulman qui disait si
bien ses prières juives que moi
évidemment je connaissais pas puisque je
suis un athée primaire secondaire tous à
extra mais en tout cas ça s'est passé
comme ça je vais vous le dire et ça
parle de quoi
pak passe au vert vas y mon anglais
passent au vert passage renaissance
résurrection celle de jésus pour les
chrétiens et la renaissance d'un peuple
le peuple juif qui fut selon l'exode
l'ancien testament de livres 1 l'ancien
testament esclaves en egypte comme des
migrants comme des migrants en
méditerranée ce peuple-là ce peuple de
pauvre type marcha vers une terre soit
disant promise face à un dieu invisible
peu sympathique et toujours en colère
moïse leur dîme et prend un autre peuple
ils veulent pas une traîne ils veulent
pas y aller est certain c'est que je
veux oui m'enfin ils veulent un vrai
dieu convoi de statut des machins ab oui
mais moi je peux pas me montrer à oui
mais c'est pas marrant parce que c'est
le club que j'ai choisi sauf à dire le
peuple et lui choisi bon et c'est très
embêtant cette histoire là parce que
moïse malheureux ils m'ont tous les sens
ils montent et descendent et ont in fine
négocié fait un geste donne l'impression
que tu es là non les autres il vaut d'or
qui disent on était bien en egypte et
oui il ya parfois des conforts dans l'
esclavage et oui parfois on est
nostalgique de l' esclavage
ça doit raisonner en vous peut-être ça
enfin il ya quelque chose là de
d'étrange dans l' esclavage
parfois une quiétude de l' esclavage
alors voilà il
cher pendant 40 ans rendez compte
quarante ans le temps d'une génération
pour qu'elle change pour qu'elle se
renouvelle et sera pour aller vers ce
pays où devait couler lemay et le miel
et non le sens des convulsions
politiques
l'iniquité et les guerres donc c'était
un rêve ce pays
c'était comme pour ces gens qui échoue à
calais vous savez ces migrants qui
échoue à calais 14 km de l'angleterre
que j'ai filmé là pour mon dernier truc
et qui rêve d'un eldorado c'est la base
selon me perds je vais être heureux là
bas et c'est ça devait être la même
chose pour eux la terre promise derrière
la montagne père promise que ne verra
jamais mais ils passaient d'esclaves à
un libre marché pour renaître faire face
à un dieu invisible et pau chaleureux
regretter le temps était esclave mais
c'est parfois comme ça c'est renaître
renaître effervescents à la vie à la
liberté et à très fermé sentent
effervescence est mer rouge
effervescente elle même que la bonté de
s'entrouvrir pour laisser passer ce
peuple du pays de la servitude à celui
de la liberté à celui la terre promise
effervescents printemps d'un peuple
effervescents printemps des peuples
effervescents printemps de chacune et
chacun d'entre nous effervescence
effervescence fête de la libération
contre les oppressions alors au les
tunisiens je suis avec vous là on est
tous ici on se connaît même sort ce
n'est pas comme ça on se connaît moi qui
suis fils de tunis je vous dis d'abord
on salut fraternel et chaleureux
vraiment moi dont le père fut
responsable ici du parti socialiste et
résistant face à la barbarie nazie
moi je vous dis je vous parle de retour
du bardo où j'étais dimanche dernier
avec le président hollande et d'autres
fils et hamida tunisie bartelone de la
noël etc
oui je vous parle d'une autre barbarie
de celles et ceux qui blasphème vraiment
dieu en tuant leurs frères en humanité
au nom de dieu ils ont le culot insensé
la feuille barbares d'oser affirmer en
criant qu'ils commettent leurs meurtres
au nom de dieu dieu s'il les entends je
ne sais pas parce que sur le mont sinaï
n'entendait pas vraiment mais cela
l'entente il sanglote de chagrin d'avoir
créé cette humanité là qui tue en son
nom et c'est son coeur à lui qui est
percé de balles et de chagrin ce sont
les mêmes turcs ont frappé paris au
coeur tunis au coeur comme ils ont tué
la hier au kenya y avoir entière partout
la même cruauté la même folie
sanguinaire
alors en ce jour de pâques juive et
chrétienne je me retourne vers vous mes
amis et frères d'ici la mère doit de
nouveau centre ouvrir et engloutir des
armes et de la cruauté et permettre à
notre société à votre société tunisienne
à ces femmes et ces hommes que je
connais si bien d'aller vers leur
libération démocratique
évidemment face à la saloperie des
dictateurs qu'ils soient imberbe ou bas
revenus vous savez je suis charlie wi je
suis tunis oui c'est partout le même cri
qui doit nous réunir
il est celui des hommes libres de tous
ceux qui disent non à l'horreur et à la
barbarie
oui à la démocratie oui aux droits de
l'homme non à la régression au pseudo
identité
ce n'est que chacun chez soi mon
identité mon identité identités
meurtrières
souvent mon identité contre la tienne
c'est épouvantable
on est tous tous tous tous pareils
différents mais quand c'est bien tassés
culturel mais pas différent comme ça
pour s'opposer les uns aux autres c'est
ridicule enfin on est différent et on
s'enrichit des uns les autres de nos
différences
évidemment on non rêverie funeste aux
rêveries funeste inspirée d'un coran mal
lu et du califat anciens du califat du
sang et d'inégalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et c'est là où il ya la
fraternité des enfants de dieu sur la
surface de la terre
non aux lectures des voiliers non à ceux
qui disent mal de l'autre côté l'ancien
testament comme un cadastre de
nos terres du côté de tel-aviv oui chers
amis je reviens du bardo et j'ai vu
là-bas les traces de cybèle de la
tunisie qui fut chrétienne de la tunisie
qui fut juive de tunisie musulmane
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui des traces c'est
cette mémoire que les assassins ont
voulu détruire traces des balles sur les
murs j'ai fait les photos atroces de
cicatrices ans il en syrie décapite les
hommes en irak il décapite les statuts
ici ils ont tué les femmes et les hommes
qui regardent les statuts alors amis
tunisien et levez vous amis tunisiens
parler haut et fort on a besoin de vous
entendre parler haut et fort comme nous
on vous dit notre solidarité
évidemment elle n'est pas simplement
affectueuse solidarité est aussi
politique évidemment alors les intellos
alors les intellectuels tunisiens faites
vous entendre haut et fort je vous en
supplie on a besoin d'entendre des voix
qui viennent de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée parfois pardonner un ami de
vous parler un langage d'amis
pardonnez-moi plus fort plus fort les
intellos plus fort les intellos tunisien
notre silence votre silence
intellectuels musulmans fut
assourdissant parfois épais opaque comme
s'il ne fallait pas rendre ses quais
l'harmonie
ils vous ont tué ici à paris n'hésite
pas à paris à tuer des dessinateurs
parce que soi disant ils sont
blasphémateurs alors que sont les tueurs
qui le sont ils ont tué des juifs parce
que juif
ils ont tué des policiers musulmans
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont les
serviteurs d'un ordre honni c'est à dire
la république et la démocratie c'est
dégueulasse alors intellectuels artistes
écrivains cinéastes journalistes parler
haut et fort c'est ça être journaliste
c'est ça être intellectuel c'est ça être
artiste évidemment vive la démocratie
vraiment exprimé par tout le peuple
magnifique ce peuple magnifique qui a
fait de vous la première démocratie du
monde arabe je sais que c'est un slogan
on rabâche à mais c'est vrai vous devez
en être fier ça se construit tous les
joueurs démocratie c'est ça qui est
important c'est qu'elle existe et c'est
ça qu'ils ont voulu démolir
ils ont voulu demander un mémoire du
bardo ils ont voulu démolir la
démocratie en tunisie alors vive la
démocratie vraiment foncer lecture de
religion asphyxiant à tunis comme tel
aviv au caire comme à sanaa en irak
comme en syrie en libye comme en algérie
non à l'oppression au nom de dieu
oui à la liberté fait je rajoute vive la
laïcité
je vous le dis franchement du fond du
coeur
combien de fois j'ai rencontré des
hommes politiques tunisiens je dis mais
pourquoi vous parlez pas de laïcité
ce mot là pourquoi vous l'employez pas
10 est intraduisible en arabe je sais
pas je parle pas arabe
je suis rien qu'un pauvre gars du
belvédère
mais enfin comment ça se fait que ce
soit intraduisible mot laïcité c'est ce
qui protège la religion ce qui protège
au contraire la religion c'est ce qui
permet aux gens de pratiquer pas
pratique et pourquoi ça serait
intraduisible en arabe dans une
démocratie
pourquoi au nom de quoi qu'on m'explique
un jour je faisais des interviews je
comprenais même parce qu on me répondait
la force
by a inventé un nouveau concept appelé
autrement démerdez vous mais en tout cas
il faut que la laïcité sont reconnus
dans la constituent
sur 2 république tunisienne ça me paraît
très très très important apparaît très
important
alors voilà vous voyez j'ai fini j'ai
fini et c'est un bon moment ça clignote
sans arrêt devant moi là j'ai été encore
une fois trop long c'est que moi quand
j'ai le cinéma quand j'étais petit
c'était un film permanent donc là je me
suis dit c'est permanent aussi ça
recommence leurs délires de ce pas je
vais retourner au palmarium au colisée
merci beaucoup